Let’s analyze them one by one. This requires at
least 1C and then you can have zero or more As.
This is CA star and we’re suppose to match
optional CA star, so this isn’t quite right. A string
that’s accepted up here A or even the empty string
is not accepted down here. Down here this finite
state machine would allow you to do
A, C, A, C, A, C, to alternate between them
because there is only one state. The regular
expression up top does not. Over here this is
looking relatively promising; if we have no C's we
can have a star that’s pretty good and we can also
have an optional C. But here is a string accepted
by this first regular expression C, AA that is not
accepted by this machine. C and then we would
fall off. So this is not a good bat, so either I’m
super evil or this last one is the winner and it turns
out that the last one is the winner. And essentially
up here we have A star and down here we have
CA star. When I put these two paths together, I
get optional C followed by A star.